Democratic presidential frontrunner Joe
Biden is out with a stark warning for
his opponents ahead of next week's
debates he says this if you come at me
this time I am ready to hit back his
threat comes amid yet another fight
centered around race between the former
vice president and Senators Kamala
Harris and Cory Booker ed O'Keefe is in
Washington with more on this story Boyet
getting feisty already so where is this
already where is this new Biden stance
coming from do you think well Gail it's
coming from and understanding that
Democrats are looking most especially
for the candidate they believe is best
equipped to defeat the president and
doing so likely requires a strong debate
to poor performance so Biden knows he's
got to step up his game then next week's
debate Wall Street did not build his
country middle class people former Vice
President Joe Biden and other Democrats
appeared this week at conferences hosted
by civil rights organizations touting
their plans to revamp the criminal
justice system but Biden also took time
to defend his record on civil rights in
part by referencing President Obama they
did a significant background check on me
for months with ten people I think my I
doubt what he would have picked me if
there's accusations about my being wrong
on civil rights is correct
Biden's lead over the Democratic field
has slipped since the first debates
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in America this week
Biden was asked about a CBS News poll
that identified California senator
Kamala Harris as the most strong
candidate among Democratic voters
I was probably overly polite in a radio
interview Thursday he also raised
questions about Harris's motives at the
first debate I thought we were friends
and we wish I hope we still will be you
know she asked me to go to her
convention and be the guy from outside
of California to nominate her at her
conventions for the Senate seat I did
Biden Harris and New Jersey senator Cory
Booker will be front and center at a
debate next Wednesday Booker is raising
doubts about Biden's new plan to revamp
federal sentencing laws and drug policy
since the former V backed tough on crime
bills in the 1990s for guy who helped to
be an architect of mass incarceration
this is an inadequate solution but Biden
hit back
raising questions about Booker's past
record as mayor of Newark New Jersey his
Police Department was stopping and
frisking people mostly african-american
men if he wants to go back and talk
about records I'm happy to do that but
I'd rather talk about the future part of
what Booker and Harris are doing is
trying to build their support among
black voters but our CBS News
battleground tracker poll out this week
gives Biden a double-digit lead over his
rivals for example in the early primary
state of South Carolina driven in part
by deep support for him among black
voters Tony all right thank you very
much